hi everyone this is professor m.science
and today i want to discuss eigenvalues
and eigenstates in tensor product state
spaces in another one of our videos on
rigorous quantum mechanics tensor
product state spaces allow us to
describe complex quantum systems using
simpler components one example is a
particle moving in three spatial
dimensions we can think of it as the
combination of a particle moving
separately in the x y and z spatial
dimensions another example is a
multi-particle system which can be
thought of as the combination of
individual separate single particle
systems the aim of this video is to
study eigenvalues and eigenstates in
these tensor product state spaces we'll
find that under certain conditions we
can build the eigenvalues and
eigenstates of the full system by simple
combinations of the eigenvalues and
eigenstates of the simpler component
systems these results find many
applications and you can find examples
by following the links in the
description which include the
three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator or a system of two
interacting quantum particles let's go
let's consider a state space v1
and in this state space we'll consider
an operator a
database this eigenvalue equation
as usual the lambda here are the
eigenvalues and the psi here are the
eigenstates
we also consider another state space v2
in which we'll work with an operator b
database this other eigenvalue equation
where the mu or the eigenvalues and the
phi are the eigenstates
starting from these two state spaces we
can build the state space v
as the tensor product between v1 and v2
we consider an operator c that acts on v
and this will be its eigenvalue equation
where the omega are the eigenvalues and
the chi are the eigenstates
what we'll do today is to limit our
discussion to a very specific form for
the operator c we'll write it as the sum
of the operator a
and the operator b
if you've seen our video on tensor
product state spaces then you'll
recognize this expression as the
extension of the operator a from its
original state space v1 to the tensor
product state space v where this sub
index indicates that the operator a
comes from v1 and where this here is the
identity operator in v2
similarly this here is the extension of
b from v2 to v
with the identity operator in v1 here
and the sub-index 2 here indicating that
b comes from v2
we need to include the identity
operators because the operator c acts on
the tensor product state space v and
therefore each of its terms must also do
that
if you haven't seen the video on tensor
product state spaces yet then i suggest
that you watch it first and you come
back to this video afterwards
so why do we limit ourselves to this
very specific form for the operator c
the reason is that we'll see that in
this case we can build the eigenvalues
and eigenstates in the tensor product
state space v up here
from the eigenvalues eigenstate of the
two individual state spaces v1 here
and v2 here
what this means is that the calculations
in the tensor product state space are
greatly simplified
however this would only be useful if we
had plenty of situations in which we
encounter operators c that take this
form
and as you may suspect this is indeed
the case
a general situation where this happens
is when we have a particle moving in the
usual three-dimensional space
in this case the full three dimensions
are described by a tensor product state
space v
made of the tensor product of the state
spaces associated with each individual
spatial dimension
as a concrete example you can check out
the video on the three-dimensional
quantum harmonic oscillator linked in
the description which is described by a
hamiltonian that is the sum of a
hamiltonian along x
a hamiltonian along y
and the hamiltonian along z
where the hamiltonian along x takes the
usual expression for the one-dimensional
quantum harmonic oscillator with its
kinetic energy part
and its potential energy part
and we would have similar expressions
for one dimensional oscillators along y
and along z
so as we can see the hamiltonian h of a
particle moving in a three-dimensional
quantum harmonic oscillator takes the
same form as the operator c that we'll
investigate today so everything we learn
will immediately be applicable to this
system
if we make some room
another common situation is a
multi-particle system such as a two
particle system
in this case the full system is
described by a tensor product state
space v
made of the tensor product of the state
spaces associated with each individual
particle
as a concrete example in the video on
two interacting quantum particles also
linked in the description we find that
the hamiltonian h of two particles
interacting by a potential that depends
on their relative position can be
written as the sum over a center of mass
hamiltonian
and a relative hamiltonian
this expression the center of mass
hamiltonian
describes a fictitious particle of mass
capital m moving freely so that we only
have a kinetic energy term
and the relative hamiltonian
is given by the kinetic energy of
another single fictitious particle whose
mass little m is the reduced mass of the
system
moving in the relative potential
u
you can find all the details about two
particle systems in the linked video and
know that here i'm using a slightly
different notation for the reduced mass
and the relative potential so we don't
confuse the terms with other important
quantities in this video
again the hamiltonian age of the two
particle system takes the same form as
the operator c that we'll investigate
today
so everything we learn will also be
immediately applicable to this system
what we learned today is that both of
these examples correspond to situations
in which the eigenvalues and eigenstates
in the tensor product state space can be
constructed from those in the individual
state spaces
what we'll do is we'll keep the
discussion general in terms of operators
a b and c
but you can think of these more concrete
examples we've just discussed if you
find that helpful
let's start by constructing the tensor
product state between psi and phi
as such this state belongs to the state
space v
which is the tensor product between v1
and v2
what i want to show next is that this
tensor product is in fact an eigenstate
of the operator c up here
to see this let's consider the action of
c
on the tensor product state
we can expand the operator c in this
special form we're considering today
all acting on the tensor product states
what we need now is to remember the
action of operators on tensor product
states from the video in tensor products
a general tensor product operator p
q acting on a general tensor product
state alpha beta
is such that the operator from the first
state space only acts on the state from
the same state space
and the operator from the second state
space only acts on the state from the
second state space
using this result we can rewrite the
action of this first term
as the tensor product of these in v1
with this in v2
and then the action of this second term
as the tensor product of this in v1
with this in v2
this here is the eigenvalue equation in
v1
the identity operator here does not
change the state the same goes for this
identity operator here
and this is the eigenvalue equation in
v2
overall we end up with lambda times the
tensor product state
plus
mu times the tensor product state
finally we can rewrite this as lambda
plus mu
times the tensor product state which is
a common factor
what does this mean
we see that the action of c on this
state
gives this scalar
times the same state
this means that the tensor product state
is an eigenstate of c
looking at the eigenvalue equation of c
up here this means that we can write the
eigenstate chi
as this tensor product state
we also see that the eigenvalue
associated with chi is lambda plus mu so
we can write the eigenvalue omega of c
as equal to lambda plus mu
and this is it
to recap let's first consider the setup
we have a state space v1
with an operator a database this
eigenvalue equation
and we have a second state space v2
with another operator b that based this
eigenvalue equation
we then build a state space v
that is the tensor product between v1
and v2
and we consider an operator c acting in
v database this other eigenvalue
equation
we've limited our discussion to
operators c
that have a specific form given by the
sum of the operator a
and the operator b
with this setup what we've shown today
is that we can construct the
eigenstate's chi of the operator c
as the tensor product of the eigenstate
of operators a and b
and that we can construct the
corresponding eigenvalues omega as the
sum of the eigenvalues of a and b
this result greatly simplifies
calculations because it means that we
can work in the simpler individual state
spaces v1 and v2
and once we've solved the problem there
we can straightaway construct the
solutions for the tensor product state
space v
and before we finish we should briefly
mention notation
when we work with tensor products we
almost always simplify notation so when
you check our other videos or any other
resources keep in mind that expressions
are just c
which is given by the sum of these two
terms
are typically simplified to this sum
over two terms where we omit the
identity operators and the tensor
product symbols
my advice is that although this simply
notation is very convenient you should
never forget that we really have tensor
products
you're now ready to apply the result
we've discussed today about eigenvalues
and eigenstates in tensor product state
spaces good examples for this include
the three-dimensional quantum harmonic
oscillator or a system of two
interacting quantum particles and as
always if you like the video please
subscribe